[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGDA JARY: Hi, Gabby.
How did this cloud certification
journey begin for you?
GABRIELLA QUERALES:
So it began because I
wanted to have limitless
possibilities in my career.
And I knew a Google
Cloud certification
will allow me to do that.
MAGDA JARY: And what was
your key personal motivation
behind earning a Google
Cloud certification?
GABRIELLA QUERALES: I wanted
to master the technology that
is shaping our life every day.
And for me, Google
Cloud technologies
and cloud technologies,
in general, they do that.
MAGDA JARY: How would
you encourage someone new
into the world of cloud to set
a goal of achieving a Google
Cloud certification?
GABRIELLA QUERALES:
Three things--
the first thing, know
that it can be done.
Even if you don't have the
right cloud background,
the right technology
background, it
can be done because I did it.
The second thing is that accept
that is going to be hard.
It's going to require a lot of
sacrifice, a lot of commitment
and discipline.
And the third thing, know
that it's totally worth it.
So go for it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]